[Music]
hello and welcome to a very special
episode of what's in the box special
about this same old [ __ ] as always man
I'm Scully Mulder Hey look how long it
took Herrmann pick that up you're
getting better though getting better
this is the show where we open up the
box and we look at what's inside we
can't do that until he does that then he
does this oh the shark has a pocketknife
and uses it to open this right Oh flash
goodness this week kids we're looking at
the fastest man alive Barry Allen who
very quickly in short order has become
one of my favorite comic book characters
of all time I always loved the most
those great sporting character but that
TV show they do and I'm not just saying
this because I want a job I got a job so
I don't have to say this that TV show
they do is astounding my name is Barry
and I am the fastest man alive this is
truly a comic book brought to life every
week they do an issue of a comic book I
gets as close to the experience as I had
reading the flash as a kid and it's
joyous it's as deep as a comic book but
that's just deep enough like for that
hour you just wanted to be invested in a
bunch of pseudoscience you want to see
friends working together wonderful damn
show man so that took that character
instantly made it more interesting to me
Geoff Johns also did a great job the
flash character during the whole new 52
is the thing that came out in the new 52
that I love flash had no backstory
he was just like he's Barry Allen he's
police forensics guy police chemist they
called and he got hit by lightning and
he turned into the flash so they gave
him this cool ass backstory has to like
his mom got killed
oh so good I like to show so much on my
teller said I haven't told anyone this
because it's embarrassing but I feel
like zoom in I when I watch it we're
about to get gold when I buy when I
watch his shout I've catch myself
walking on house gonna be like the show
touching I feel like a young Barry Allen
I lost a mom and Baba instead you're
like when I watch flash I pretend to run
real fast
that's your confession against Moore
Barris everybody now [ __ ] my wife ads
the flash I'm like ching-ching she's
like that was fast he's like you know
run Barry run
so they've done such a good thing a such
great job with this character he's into
the mainstream even my mom is like all
flash this week I'm like what the [ __ ]
you jeez like run Barry run
so this thing is everywhere minutes on
the CW we got a bunch of flash stuff to
play with this week let's look at it
let's let's go old school first this was
live from the super powers collection
when I was a kid Kenner once again the
name that is the stamp of childhood
quality and fun when you see the word
Kenner that meant your parents loved you
enough to buy you [ __ ] [ __ ] right out
the store man instead of stealing [ __ ]
out the garbage of your friends
superpowers collection dude look at that
amazing lineup now if you saw DC making
these characters right now you'd be like
well of course superheroes very invoke
this was 1984 they did an action figure
line of Superman Batman Robin Green
Lantern that's deep cuts right there
flash Aquaman Hawkman is insanely deep
cuts for a mainstream character Wonder
Woman Lex Luthor Brainiac Joker and
Penguin each one came with a mini comic
it was fantastic look they did a Hall of
Justice
they did a Batmobile Superman have
vehicle Lex Luthor this line was the
[ __ ] dude was the [ __ ] you talk too long
I'm sorry I got excited dude like it and
it shows the legs SuperSpeed legs yeah
like look at that I think did you
screeches pleasing the others
appreciation oh he's not going so well
here well it isn't old baby I think
you're supposed to squeeze them together
now I thought were squeezed
yes fest here maybe we stretch him out
in this mini comic book dude he's
fighting Brainiac and yeah you could
join the fan club official superpowers
fan club charter membership form dude
how much I'll join expires June 30th
1985 just missed it
looks like a Carmine Infantino flash
they sold you comics in your toys so
they were like hey kids you like this
you couldn't subscribe to these various
comics very very cold man let's touch
this bad boy flash from the Superfriends
this is probably the way most people of
our generation remember flat because we
keep on the Superfriends cartoon
there's the superfriends their versions
of your favorite DC characters they're
just friendlier I guess we're all buds
they don't have the Wonder Twins not yet
but they would later on I think they
wound up okay I believe a lot of the
Superfriends stuff was like design by
Alex Toth I think or something like that
so that might have here you play with
that these runs actually extended two
wings out I never speed on his boots
[Applause]
berries police badge this is uh this is
not why is it as the Kazak he works I
guess glad there's a [ __ ] doctor
nobody's father that raised Joe Joe
what's up Anthony stepfather like a good
point man there's a father figure
includes leather mount and chain the
flash Central City badge insignias you
don't have to be the guy they make you
you're just you're Jay Mewes who happens
to be CSI that's pretty happy I'm here
to check out the scene and see if
there's any DNA or leave some of your
own there yes that he's like don't worry
it'll be fast open that dude smart why
do you like Captain cold so much I think
he's great the do to place Captain Cold
on flash now he's on legends of tomorrow
Wentworth Wentworth Miller yes and Barry
tell you I had a rough childhood he's
got a great delivery I've only seen him
as as captain look cool but you've seen
him in something I'll put some bread
I love this patois on flash Mardon broke
Jesse and me out to kill you
Jesse's on board of course he's shaking
with excitement me I'm in a panic acting
is all about choices man when an actor
an actor's makes a choice that makes you
remember that performance they made the
right choice though this dude made the
right choice man whenever you watch he
pops up on that show you're like oh he's
he's fast you can't take your eyes off
and off him because he's figuring out a
new way to deliver like a line that
you've heard a thousand times it's not
my problem
you said that you love it here that this
is your home I do and it is dig it
I dig his character like you said he
does make you sit deliver the dialogue
Martin wants revenge Jesse wants chaos
and just not invested like they are even
on legends of tomorrow and it's good -
oh you're not quite ready to run with
this crew I'm sorry kid
rant here man let it go here's our boy
this kid makes it work do you know how
hard it is to paw off the [ __ ] flash
I'm gonna have to power through it like
about all the DC characters it's tough
to pull off cuz it's kind of like you've
run fast dude what can you do
everyone makes fun of Aquaman honestly
flash is the [ __ ] joke but they
turned him into something viable where
you're like oh my god the flash is like
the best character of DC shows what a
bunch of good writers could do with like
any material may take material scene one
thousand times
make it a thousand dollars better but
the little boy in this suit or a Gustin
he makes you love the flash dude when he
watched his mom get spoilers watch his
mom gets killed I can't save her cuz
other flash which is him is like going
like that yeah oh guy said maybe don't
even do it you just did it I was like
that was it it's so emotional if you
haven't seen that flash season 1 season
finale it'll knock your [ __ ] socks
off in the flash I cried harder that
been the birth of my child I get my
second chance to come back here
tell you that I'm ok alright I almost
got him out the flash may be fast but
the guy taking the flash out of the
packaging is limited by a superpower of
not being able to [ __ ] remove
anything from the package that's the
difficult he's got a bunch of hands they
seem to like giving these characters
intense now what does his have though
maybe cold maybe he's like the cold oh
maybe I got that freeze
I do like the jacket they just thrown
the little jacket and stuff in his
glasses and the whole business it's very
close Catskills that without looking
like a uniform or custard yes
this looks like his costume from almost
from season one I thought look at his
tiny little fists compared to Wentworth
Miller spits
oh my god this guy's gonna kill on again
your low weight he's done flashed the
human male geisha look how tiny is
everything small about the figures are
great did they have a lot of
articulation just like and these ones
have kneecaps
it's my this one doesn't ah step hinge
good off the hinge too if you go like
that it's turban kneecap yeah yeah I'm
not judging these are Finn says that the
design on these figures man like look at
that that you could tell that that's
Grant Gustin you can tell this yeah yeah
it comes off DC collectibles they make a
hell of a good-looking figure they need
to make more flash figures though more
from the flash universe man like a Cisco
figure because somebody to name all the
characters that come in this day yes
that's his team leaders telling you like
that when he started doing it the very
first when he started throwing that name
Captain clone the mist Captain Cold
you gotta stop naming these guys dude I
like anything where they gets a
reference count book character write
goals and stuff and like they did an
episode where they brought on the turtle
turtle like well Lana's characters in
the flash universe and they made it work
and it was actually pointing
what would you pay for all this stuff
let's talk about price maybe price with
the tiniest little hands later captain
cold and the flash I would say is a good
1999 the captain cold and flash figure
2495 alright the Kenner figure 50 bucks
close man it goes for 35 to 40 on ebay
the inline initially sold well back last
after three years on the market like I
remember that it came on strong and then
people like we don't care about this but
Jack Kirby plotted out the comic book
tie and also called superpowers that
Jack Kirby working on the show back in
the day oh here your your Super Friends
yes how much would you pay for this this
is 35 I'd say 40 you're gonna pay about
20 to 40 bucks if you're planning this
on ebo none because these the figures
they did them and then they went away
and they stopped and that was it made it
more valuable he's a good looking flash
too they are both or more what about the
badge what would you pay for the badge
how much we've now we've seen a badge
from the Aero TV show collective Lance's
badge I think here's at say $35 $29.99
very close by you can pretend to be a
cop with this I'm telling you you can go
you shake down some people's if you find
people playing three-card Monte in the
subway mm take them down with this be
like I'm here from Central City like
where's that know like on earth-2 or
they're playing craps in the corner you
know I don't need a badge to be a
concerned citizen just going to be like
a kids are walking here you can't say
we're playing ha yeah they took yeah
that's what you get for put your nose to
somebody else's business
oh man in the world where we're going
with the theme I bet y'all know what
that is lift it up this that's what I'm
talking about this is quality [ __ ] your
stupid badge snaps sighs yes dude Oh sue
Jess the suit
this right here is the backwards Flash's
Rock welfare Alan and eobard thawne
store costumes and the rings you're
peeing it pops out it expands he gets
into himself
I can't believe they've made it the only
thing would have made this better is
that they put a tiny fake suit inside
and it blew up well come on [ __ ] dick
dude God what an American you are I want
more tiny slow suit would we clone up
and look is utterly wearable maybe not
on that for yeah oh my god I would
totally wear hey yeah totally I feel
like what's that I'm like well it
symbolizes my love of my wife and the
symbolize my love the flash yes but this
has a handy-dandy little [ __ ] snuff
hello right that's cool dude right and
it's very in keeping with the show and
with the character man I love in the
show vibe asked him how he has a ring he
did at one point it's like how'd you get
your suit in the ring how'd you get your
suit in your ring because that means one
day Cisco is gonna put berries Susan the
ring it's made of a zinc alloy with 24
gold plating lightning bolts on the ring
matches the one on reverse flashes
costume ear bought for that is my
favorite thing on this table
well that ring come on dude you don't
hurry speed that it opens I can't
believe we live in a [ __ ] world where
you could buy a [ __ ] flash ring that
actually opens up that's crazy how much
would you pay for that because I'll tell
you right now what they're asking I'd
pay way more I would say forty dollars
thirty nine nine dollars they over
thirty four ninety five I would've paid
100 bucks for that you easily could have
got me to overpay for that flash ring
but thank you very much I'll take it for
thirty four ninety five suckas you got
by two maybe how about three to help it
all [ __ ] yeah man like like when Hal
Jordan
a lot of rings from the Green Lantern
Corps and he was like I'm [ __ ] dots
and then he turned into paralyzed yes Oh
My gods amazing look at this crap man
this is fantastic this ring alone has
made my week like that this exists makes
me so happy all this [ __ ] makes me happy
dude there it is flash man you want to
see us pull stuff out of the box maybe
stuff not superhero related go to screen
junkies on the Twitter on her Facebook
page or right here at this address tell
somebody of import and they'll let us
know and we'll open it right [ __ ]
here
as we do every week we're not afraid we
got a knife with joy yeah happiness I
just with joy that was the original
title of the show thanks for hanging out
on knives of the joy man I've been Kevin
Smith
JC Muse and what's in the box this week
has been a [ __ ] ton of Flash stuff man
show him your flash run fast like you
just watched the show that's what we all
do we all it's a fly baby we don't do
that for you
[Music]
you